all right welcome back guys to the final
episode of demo rpg at least final
public episode uh more at the end all
right so this is what we have so far in
our main implementing our library doing
our thing it's the loop as you saw from
the end of last episode which maybe
you've seen maybe haven't but i've been
playing warrior here because they are
kind of op and also not everything's
fleshed out but the warrior at least
gets level three abilities so things are
dropping we got a character sheet we can
equip stuff we can use stuff we can use
oh potions we get a couple starting
items i want to equip all that stuff
nice that's a nice start right there oh
we got a one-handed sword too okay so
we've also discovered that swords are op
because there's no other way to increase
your damage unless you get lucky and get
the melee weapon drop but you know
that's just the
naiveness of her design so this is like
an op run already we just one shot that
monster and we got some gloves okay so
we have a ton of armor we are decked
already let's see if we can get
abilities working in combat that's going
to be the main thing this time and i
would like to have time to to work out
the buffs and stuff but there's so much
i want to do but there's just not time
to do everything so we just got to pick
and choose like i'll quickly go over
what i would like to do i would like to
flesh out the monsters more give them
abilities give them a little ai because
right now they're just
hit points and some attack damage that's
all literally all they do i would like
to flesh out the random items to do more
cool stuff and have more variety i would
like to make this an actual graphical
game where you can walk around and has
music and sound effects and all that
cool stuff but there's just no way we
have time for that let's go ahead and
get some abilities working so mainly
this is going to go off these fight
sequences because we aren't really going
to use the abilities anywhere else at
least for now maybe we want to be able
to use like the clerics heal ability out
of combat but for now we're not going to
worry about that we're just going to do
combat only so the main thing we need to
do is we just need to show the option so
currently when we're in combat it's the
whole fight sequence and uh while we're
alive
uh and this is why it's our turn
basically we get these options right now
we have attack or inventory so now we're
just going to say you can press b for
abilities and
we need to
do this we need to
enter some kind of ability selection and
all right so we need to design this
ability function so let's
make this a bulk enter ability selection
maybe we'll say combat ability selection
so basically what we want to do is go
through the main character and see what
abilities they have that are not on
cooldown so we can do that by first
getting the list of abilities let's just
temporarily get a list here current
abilities equals main character dot us
dot get ability list
and if we go look at this function we
can see what it does it's similar to the
get item list that we were using last
time
now the const didn't seem to have as
much effect on item pointers i thought
well this is not pointers though this is
actually going to get us a vector of
abilities but it is going to be a copy
it says it returns the player to
abilities but it's a copy of their
abilities
so we got to think about this a little
bit if we look at these abilities you
can see what all they have we're going
to get a copy of a list of these
so we just need to display them
basically and let you choose one
so let's just do that i'll start by
displaying them uh let's call it
for bill and current abilities
and we'll just show them all uh some
standard c out for now but that's what
we've been using
and what we should probably do is let
you be able to select one so let's have
a little selection integer the inventory
you can basically move your cursor
should we do the same thing here yeah i
guess we will
so let's take all this same code
basically and yeah
well the selected item's going to be
about the same actually but we're just
doing it on abilities instead of
our list of items now
saying is of course with uh the items
you actually use them up so they
disappear with
this kind of stuff obviously don't use
them up they might go a cool down though
so we have to work on that
most of the stuff's gonna be quite
relevant selected let's change selected
item number to selected
ability and same thing we're gonna stay
in here
uh until we're either done or an action
was used do we need to refresh this list
i'm not sure if we're actually going to
in this case so let's just leave that
off
and we'll say current abilities here but
as you can see you might kind of notice
a trend here once you work out one
system
sometimes the other systems are very
similar
so there's a lot of times where once you
get one thing figured out the rest of
the stuff comes a lot easier because
it's kind of similar it's just you gotta
adjust things a little bit okay we need
this to be
abilities and lists now yes this time
change it to that
change this to abilities
let's change the selected ability
we'll use that same cursor
and oh yeah i was talking in one of
those episodes about the ternary
operator that thing returns so if we
want to do it this way what we would
have to do is go standard c out
and then put the operator
it actually wouldn't look too bad uh
like this
and then like this
so this would be how you do it which is
a lot less code so it would basically
you do the c out and what are you see
outing whatever it returns it's either
this one or this one
so if it's true this one is false this
one so that would that would be how you
use it
and uh yeah that's definitely a lot
cleaner okay we need to display the bill
name
so it'll just be a build.name
me just play the name no pointers here
yeah this
this function is definitely going to
require some improvements probably it
might be well i wanted to say it's going
to be too slow but
we're just doing little console stuff
even if it is a tiny bit slow we're not
going to recognize that it's it's such a
small amount of data okay so we say the
abilities name but instead of
you know
quantity or anything we probably want to
say
the cool down i guess and what else not
only the cool down
but it's cost so we couldn't say stuff
like that so let's just do that let's go
cost
hold on we need to i need to look at
abilities again let's take a look at
these abilities
i'm gonna go deep into this ability a
bill okay
assume mp if there is a cost so
most things are not gonna have a cost
right now because we don't really have
mp that well flushed out we're not
working on casters really too much but
they're definitely gonna have a cool
down
so we could display some of this stuff
um i think we're just going to display
whether it's on cooldown or whether it's
ready and we need to keep track of
that too so we need if we use something
we need to keep track of how long it's
been so we can see when we can use it
again now it's going to be a little bit
tricky we probably should design that
actually within the ability
or something like that like how long
it's been on cooldown because we have uh
basically overlooked that since we don't
need it let's get rid of all this code
there and instead we'll just say
cool down
left
and we're going to have to work this out
a little bit
or maybe we just don't display it if
it's on cooldown but in any case as we
go through rounds we're going to have to
reduce the uh
the cooldown count or increase it or
however you're doing it because we need
to show it when it's ready
so that's something i got to think about
here for a minute all right so this cool
down problem where we need to keep track
of cooldowns but since we can't actually
edit these current abilities because
we're getting a copy list presents a bit
of a problem and now this is the point
where you can test your c plus plus
knowledge because you can ask yourself
how do we solve this problem and see
what you can come up with and if you
can't come up with anything you probably
need to learn a little bit more and uh
understand a little bit more you know
this
that's just an example of uh when you're
working on a project
things like this come up and you got to
come up with the solution and sometimes
it's a great test to see if you even
have the ability to come up with a
solution
and
that's all it takes sometimes a lot of
times all people want all
uh i don't know say managers or
something all they want is they want you
to be able to come up with some kind of
solution it doesn't need to be the best
in the world just needs to get the job
done well there are several different
things we can do here that come to mind
we could
i don't really like any of them that are
coming to mind the best one i'm thinking
of is to basically do what we did with
items where we get a where we change
these all to pointers instead that would
also improve the efficiency in general
of this sort of function but that's
going to be a lot of library work
because basically what we got to go do
is go to our player character and
wherever our list of abilities are
abilities
we would need to change this to a
pointer all right and that's going to
cause
a lot of errors which is exactly what we
want because we can hit build and we can
see exactly where we need to change
everything a little compiler error
driven architecture here and we just got
to flip through and fix all this stuff
well we can't fix x memory because
that's part of the standard template
library but we want to see where in our
class
we're doing stuff wrong now this is
mainly going to be in the cpp files okay
so we changed that let's just go to
abilities now or i guess to play our
character
and just see where all it has errors
this needs to change to returning a
pointer and we need to update this
and the header as well get ability list
where are you
same thing there
okay so there's one thing let's go ahead
and hit build again obviously it's not
going to like the pushbacks or anything
or the add ability none of that stuff is
really going to work
properly anymore so let's go to our
warrior first let's check out our
warrior and i'm just going to clap some
of this down
and here where we do in place back now
we would have to place back new memory
so we would go new ability
and that should be happy
because it will just construct like so
we can do that for all the classes this
will solve the majority of the errors
just going through these four classes
and do doing this and what this is going
to allow us to do is basically the same
thing we were doing with our items where
we could
go find the data that it's being pointed
to and change stuff and you'll see why
here in a minute why we'd want to do
that because i think what we're going to
end up doing is refactoring these
abilities a little bit now we don't want
to have to go through the whole route of
making an ability manager like we did
with the items because we're not going
to be able to like move abilities around
or anything like that there's going to
be locked to a character so no need for
all of that
but we do want to be able to change the
cooldown stuff because that's going to
be relevant okay let's say play again
it's like we already solved the majority
of the errors just a few left
okay and the rest are
not too bad okay so that was it
the rest are just we haven't updated
this function
so this should be selected ability
comparing to the current abilities dot
size
okay and the use there is
we'll figure that out here in a second
right now we should at least show the
name of abilities so let's just test
this out see if this builds
okay so let's
jump in with uh let's jump in with a
wizard oh we got a bit of a crash okay
so something was null pointer all right
fair enough let's uh try it with warrior
let's see if that's yeah warrior's fine
all right so we're doing something wrong
there with wizard we'll have to analyze
that here in a second it might be where
we gained that ability so let's see if
we can level up here no abilities okay
oh we can't seem to exit the abilities
or maybe it's just not updating the
display
okay so we got a few bugs in there
and we're gonna have to sort those out
all right so changing our abilities to
pointers also broke some of our tests so
we're gonna just fix those quick let's
build our tests try to run them see what
happens and we'll just fix these up real
quick so back into test world
you get some errors and it won't run so
basically
uh yeah we're just gonna have to use
little
pointers everywhere anywhere we're
messing with ability list
and that should pretty much be it
also where we test our warrior we can
now check our level three ability if we
want so we could go
something like this
gain another 300 xp
three
level
three check for oh power attack i think
we put a space in here now we have
healing surge
and we want to check that their base hp
is correct okay let's see if that fixes
all that so let's try to run a test
again make sure these all pass
uh we got some fails so stuff we have
changed probably made some of this not
work quite the same let's address
warrior first
and see where it messed up
expected three actual four on
level okay so maybe we gain too much xp
let's just try like that
okay expected healing surge actual power
attack oh because we did front uh
we don't want the front this would be
the second ability so it would be at
that spot and let's see if that works
oops wrong button we want to run tests
here
okay where you're still not working
we got
basically the wrong amount of hp
looks like we need to do this twice
on the test so
okay so i keep hitting play so i hit the
test again
okay so warrior now passes everything's
there there's correct it's next ability
and checking level three all looks good
let's check equip player now we did
change some of these
and a few previous episodes so it's
probably let's see which one
failed auto backpack exercise
[Music]
oh trying to equip potions now does
nothing so that's probably why
so if we really
yeah so this should just
yeah essentially do nothing
backpack size should be zero now
equivalent potion should
do nothing
but it does return false right let's
check
yeah if it's potion return false all
right so let's see if that one works now
we'll run that again
yep all our tests passed now okay so we
straighten that out i'm gonna go ahead
and make that commit excitement warrior
tests there we go looks good
oh i should have put
also in there
let's see if it allows us to modify the
message
yeah it does sweet
so you just right click on it and go to
view commit details you get a message
here
fix item
oh no it doesn't actually oh we gotta
click edit okay item slash warrior tests
hold on this isn't actually accurate
slash ability list now pointer
okay so that's a terrible commit because
it's three different things and one
commit but
uh we're gonna not worry about that too
much
so let's go ahead and commit all the
ability list changes here
which is all this stuff
ability list now pointers okay
now we just got to get our main worked
out
okay back to the combat abilities okay
so now we want to refresh this combat
ability list every time we go into this
loop kind of like we're doing with the
inventory
because it's going to change a little
bit as you'll see shortly but another
thing we want to do to the abilities
here let's just go to our abilities
in the header so they have a cool down
number of rounds you need to wait for
using the end let's go ahead and put in
here
rounds
weighted
or
something like that so
maybe we'll call it cooldown left
[Music]
and we want that to basically be zero
all the time if it's ready so let's just
put that in here well we don't have
anything in the constructor let's go to
the cbp
here's the default constructor and let's
just go ahead and pull down left so it's
a zero
should take care of that
go ahead and build everything make sure
it succeeds
looks good
so now that we're working with ability
here abilities destruct what we probably
want to do
[Music]
is
make it a class
and make it so things can't be modified
because all this stuff right here be
public means that the end user can
modify it at will which is a little
dangerous so let's just go let's just
change this to a class
make everything up here public
and let's also have a private section
down here
and let's put this pool down left up
into public
everything else i think we want to be
private
and we probably want to make accessors
to it
that way people can't just mess with
this stuff at will you have to do it on
construction only once it's constructed
can't change it
and uh yeah maybe you'll want to change
it at some point but we'll address that
if
the time comes but for now let's just
make
getter setters for like all of these so
think get cool down
i guess we're just going to do them in
line here i don't
know
yeah we'll
type them out that's fine
what else do we do we're going to get
name
that's a string though
i guess we're just gonna want all of
these really
and there we go we got all this typed up
now we probably also want to do the same
thing here like
no discard because if you're getting
these values you better be doing
something with them otherwise why are
you getting them they also want to be
cons they can't change anything
and we also want them all to be no
exception const over here
too
so we'll just copy that stuff and just
paste it down it's pretty quick to do
and what we can do is use visual studio
to generate
the stuff in the cpp hold alt and press
enter and it'll pop up this thing great
definition of there we go we can just
return whatever it is
let me just go down and do that for all
of them
pretty quick
so the buff one returns a pointer the
cost point is a little different because
it's well i guess it's still the same
but it'll just be a copy of a pointer
that you're not allowed to modify so
pretty standard actually i guess now
these ability scalers are different a
little different because they return and
kingdom
but it's not too confusing i don't think
it's target
scalar is scalar and last but not least
the cost
and of course just the dust
and now if we don't like the name of any
of these variables we can always go
through do the rename
thing with control r r yeah i think
we're good here cool down is now exposed
everything else you gotta use a getter
now that's gonna break a lot of stuff in
our code so let's go ahead and fix that
up first of all let's just build
our demo rpg make sure everything's
fixed here see if we're getting errors
no errors okay cool
but in our unit test we're probably
going to have some errors
yep as expected some of them just don't
even build now it says cannot access
private stuff so that's totally expected
and we just need to change these all to
get basically
get named get buff
get buff it's like going to the gym
all right let's see if that's enough
let's try to build these again now we
got some more areas where we used it
specifically looking at the tests here
let's go here yep
name get hp effect
and looks like we have some more down
here at the bottom
just where we're checking our
[Music]
classes and where they gain abilities
this is a little bit tedious but this is
the price you pay if you mess up your
design early on as you basically pay the
price of prefactor one of the reasons it
pays off the design first and code later
all right and there we go we fixed all
the tests
and we'll go ahead and commit those
changes pretty isolated
okay abilities
mostly private
use getters school down
left added
okay there we go push those changes
i guess i didn't necessarily need to
push them but uh that's fine
now if you're real clever you can go
look at the repo and see exactly when
i'm recording this by that push time
now another thing we should be doing
here is since we're adding uh cool down
left here we should also add a test to
make sure the cooldown is working but
basically all we're gonna do
is compare
the you know okay whenever the thing
whatever you use the thing let's find it
here
whenever you use the ability
you should set the cooldown left to the
cooldown and then every round you just
do a minus minus on it and once it's
zero there's no cooldown left you can
once again use it if you try to use it
or something you can just see what the
cooldown left is
and if you come some kind of special
thing that says reset all cooldowns you
can just set all cooldowns left to zero
you know stuff like that so yeah we
should add a test but i'm going to skip
over that for sake of time
so back into our main and back into
combat abilities selection we have made
some improvements here that should let
us
do this a little better
but things are acting a little
wonky here
things are definitely not perfect and i
noticed also we have a bug so we start
out the game
by giving the player two random items
right uh where is it right here
now there's a chance this drop random
item returns nothing or returns null
let's see yeah if you get
there's like about a 10
chance that it returns null pointer
so that's interesting right what if that
happens then you just get nothing
yeah but actually it ends up throwing an
error because if we go into our main
we're just calling move to backpack and
if we look at move to backpack
checks if there's an item or not
checks that there's data in the item but
we don't want to do this get item check
actually uh because
it's hard to explain but basically if
there's an item
or if the item to move is null if we try
to do this it's going to give you a
dereference error and crash so what we
actually should be doing is going like
this and then another case here
for this one so it does it holy separate
also just returns pulse
because uh
yeah
we don't we don't necessarily know if
this is going to evaluate left to right
or right to left
so we're not really going to be able to
bank on this that i think it's undefined
i'm not 100 sure on this but some
compilers
will implement stuff like this
differently so thus they'll say it's
undefined because your compiler could do
it differently it's not in the
specification i thought it was right to
left evaluation but i could be wrong
because i did see a crash when i wasn't
recording on this particular thing
and it was because it was calling this
get data when item to move was null uh
but it was all the way on the left as
you saw so it shouldn't if it was
evaluating right to left so i don't know
it'd be better to just completely make
it separate like so
so uh take that for what you will
there's a chance you will not start out
with two items there's a chance one's
going to be null and this will just
return false
so this move to backpack we'll be
returning something we're not even
checking what it's returning because it
doesn't particularly matter
and it doesn't have no discard so it's
going to let us do that without
complaining
[Music]
okay so let's go back up here actually
let's just give this a run
and see what we get here
i made a wizard we're attacking let's go
to our abilities we see fireball
now we haven't made we haven't put the
use code in so it doesn't do anything
but we should be able to hit done and
get out of this go back to our combat
menu but that doesn't seem to be
happening
so what's going on there
let's see we are in this loop
we have done an action used and if
either of those become true
we should exit this while okay
oh and i figured out this operator thing
that was displaying a one
it looks like we have to wrap it in
outside brackets otherwise i think it
was
ending up with just a c out of whether
this was true or not which would be a
one or a zero so
looks like you gotta just wrap it in
cases like this so all right so let's
analyze further down here we have a get
care switches now if we enter d it
should set done to true
and then break out of the switch
statement
and then done should be true so it
should break out of this while loop turn
action used
and then we'd be
back down in our main while loop here we
should be going back to fight sequence
i'm going to change the name of this to
just fight
sequence
and oh man this must be returning
something incorrectly as well not sure
why but
if this ends up being false which it
should be action you should be false if
we hit done this would return none in
action taken will be none
so thus we will still be in this loop
here and it should display
the
this little action interface again
but for some reason it's not doing that
so let's hit play again let's give it
another shot and just see what happens
here yeah we just can't get out of the
abilities so why not let's combat
ability selection let's go to the switch
statement let's put a break on this d
and see if it's even setting it done to
true
because that seems to be the problems
they'll fight
our abilities done yeah it's setting
down to true okay so let's
let's just step through this a little
bit and see what's going on
it's not breaking out of this loop why
not
done is true
why would it not break out of this
oh do i have these backwards
okay so i guess i just have this logic a
little bit wrong but why is it working
for inventory then not sure let's change
this to ability done see so while either
of these are valid the action used is
still valid so that's the problem and
why it's still continuing why would it
do it here though so let's see if we hit
d on this one should do the same thing
let's try it with the combat inventory
and see if that one big bugs out too all
right so go fight go to inventory hit
done okay it doesn't yeah her logic is a
little incorrect
all right let's think about why this is
incorrect because this is important this
was definitely in the last few episodes
and
as of this recording no one's pointed it
out so no one else is caught either but
it's pretty straightforward okay this or
says this entire thing evaluates to true
if either of these are true or any of
them are so we need to
do this a little different
because we want to break out of this if
either
are
true basically so we probably want to go
let's see this break here will break out
of the while loop but we probably just
want to instead
let's see here yeah let's just rework
this a little bit
so we'll keep the ability done in there
that's fine let's also say
uh
just after this entire switch statement
here so like right here
if
action used break
now what that's going to do since it's
outside the switch statement is just
going to break out of this while loop
and then return the action used we could
also optionally say return action used
right here but since we have it at the
bottom we're just going to keep it like
that so we can do that with the combat
inventory as well
i think that's going to be the easiest
way to do this here same thing yep
actually used to break out of the while
loop
all right so that should fix that issue
we should actually be able to
dive in there again let's just test it
out abilities hit done
okay there's that breakpoint very good
let's continue
and we are back in combat so yeah now we
can go to our abilities and just look at
it at will as we should be able to same
with inventory we just want to look at
it and not use up our turn very well
there we equipped
and the monster hurt us back so we did
use their action there all right cool
[Music]
all right so that fixed a few things
let's be smart about this and just
commit our small things fix no rep pace
on this item manager go ahead and commit
that push it
uh let's
oh we need to commit first
we'll push later
all right
what are we doing on our main here we
got quite a few changes queued up
but mainly our see combat inventory
so yeah we've got several things here
it's kind of hard to break them up in
visual studio but there's this piece of
software i talked about it all down on
my channel all four
support them if you use them but it lets
you
in a single file like this main it lets
you specify things like you can just
highlight the section and say we only
want that to square that line so you can
make little individual commits
so on this one the combat inventory
example
go like this
and just stage those changes and just
make like fix
leaving inventory
so we can commit little individual
pieces uh
this one is
ability collection oh we're not actually
done with this yet so let's wait
actually
so we still need to actually make it do
something with this you don't do
anything yet
but we did rename this fight sequence so
that's kind of relevant go ahead and uh
commit that maybe
yeah
okay
name fight
sequence
so that's the great thing about fork is
you can just individually pick little
pieces to commit at once
but uh looks like we're still working on
this combat ability but now it's that's
all that's left there
so let's finish it up before we make all
those commits but yeah that's that's
super nice i love it
so let's look at this again combat
ability selection got the name
uh we were working on the cooldown a
little bit but
let's just go ahead and get the used
code in here
so what we have to do is return some
sort of damage if it's used basically
well it could be damage or it could be
healing
so this needs to be a bit modular
this can also put a buff on your player
so we're going to have to expand this a
lot there's no way we're going to get
this all
done right now but what we could do as a
quick hack is put an end here
by reference
and say alt
effect or out hp effect
all right and that way when we call
combat ability selection we can have a
variable prompt and ready of how much hp
it affects
and we could say we could assume
something like if it's negative it's
doing damage or well i don't know i
gotta think about that i guess
maybe we even just have it
do its thing directly
yeah let's just have it do its thing
directly
so say you use the ability alright what
do we need to know if
current abilities
uh
at the selected ability.get
hp effect
or well we need no cell dot get target
get target
that equals
ability target
yeah we just need to switch on this
basically
ally enemy yourself basically we're only
using enemy itself right now so let's
just keep it simple so if it's if it
targets an enemy there's only one enemy
so we can keep it straight forward and
say all right well the target's an enemy
it's a damage effect basically we're
just going to keep it that simple i know
it can do more
but uh we're not gonna worry about that
the other case is it's yourself so if it
targets yourself then it's gonna be a
heal basically because those are the
only things we do right now so let's
just get the damage
and apply it to uh the monster's health
cause i think that's all we're gonna do
if we look at our combat logic a little
more if i sequence here yeah we do the
damage directly in line so we can just
do it right here and that'll be done in
the function
and the only thing we have after we're
done is the monster hits us if it's
still alive
so let's go ahead and do this
if it's the enemy let's have him take
damage it's going to be the same as this
function basically
current monster
monster hp reduce and we want to get
that current ability
at the selected
ability
and then
get hp effect basically and then we want
to add the scalar
now the scalar there's three different
scalars
so scalar is a little odd
yeah these aren't very well fleshed out
because what the we would say we use
power attack let's say we use power
attack let's look at the warriors uh
power attack and just see what it does
exactly here uh warrior power attack
it says if we look at ability it says it
does hp effective four but really it's
gonna do
your current weapon plus four is what it
meant for it to do
there's no way to really say that so
whatever we'll just
we'll just leave it how it is for now
and add the scalar
but we're gonna need to do some more
logic here so let's just work it out
uh damage or we'll get a total damage
here it started at zero
and we'll add this to it total damage
plus equals the hp effect and then we
need to add the scalar uh so we'll just
like switch on the scaler i guess go
like this again
get scalar
that's going to return
one of the stats so
ace ability scaler
strength and we also got uh index
right
or we're calling it agility so there's
our cases
the default break at the bottom if it's
the strength we want to get the main
characters
uh got us
get straight
or get total strength and we're going to
divide that by two
because that's generally how we scale
everything 50 basically
which is not necessarily the best scale
but here we go we go total damage
plus equals
that
just go ahead and scale that right on
there and we'll cast this to an end
because it's going to turn into a float
with this divisor
all right let me do the same thing with
the end and agility acceptance to get
total strength it's the other ability
there we go now we got that applied
okay let's get rid of those extra lines
oh there we go we've got the u's working
uh that's if the enemy or the target is
an anim target's not an enemy we're
going to the else case which is
basically going to be a heal
and in this case we're going to go oh
wait did we do the reduced current we
gotta pick total damage at the bottom
yeah
else
we'll just say here
it's it's a heal
probably
for now that's good enough
and we'll do a similar thing we'll go in
total heal
started at zero
and we'll just do the same thing the hp
effect of the heal
and then do this same switch
except it's all total heal
i imagine most heals are going to scale
up intellect
but you never know we could have some
interesting abilities that don't at the
end we'll just go main character
heal for total
and that should take care of most
abilities right there and we want to
make sure that action taken is true
after all this too right so we go action
use
[Music]
and that way we will break and we'll
know we used our action there we go
all right so let's run this and give it
a little test we'll start out with a
wizard
go to battle use an ability let's use
firebolt
well that's not working as intended
because the monster has zero hp but
we're still in combat so what's going on
there
good question
good question so something on our fight
sequence is wrong though that's pretty
safe to assume
[Music]
we're definitely not breaking out of
this
while loop as intended
so why not
uh let's put a break point like right
here
and just have a test see what's going on
now that's a quick oh we got two potions
that's a nice start okay let's go to
fight
ability
use fireball okay it goes to this i'll
just skip down a little bit
and it should break combat ability
selection while not ability done okay
why is it going back up here
okay well
i thought break would get out of the
while loop
okay i know
it's because
where
this action used needs to also be on the
damaged one i was i only put it on the
heel so if we use it either one okay i
guess we could even put it like at this
right here
so after it does either it'll just say
action so we were actually breaking yes
break will get out of the while loop but
we do have to actually set it
so we were doing this one which didn't
have the ability use or action used set
to true but now either either way if you
hit you
it's gonna break out of there
yep so that should work
all right so let's go ahead and try it
again
wizard go to battle user ability use
fireball
you won first the monster cool
so firebolts working now the thing is uh
fireball
we're just able to use it at will
basically because
we're not actually checking the mp so we
can just firebolt every time
and it's probably a little op yeah we
can one shot the monster every time with
fireball
it's just
broken
wizard broken class
all right so let's just check our
character yeah we're looking pretty good
because it does whatever its base damage
is plus half here and like so it does at
least four damage every time just just
busted
let's equip this neck guard with these
boots i'm just gonna play for a minute
put the helmet with the boots
and we're done
all right let's look at our character
sheet nice we are properly decked
and let's uh yeah our attacks aren't
very great but if we go use our fire
bolt we can just install one shot every
time
all right cool well we could pretty much
do this endlessly
this monster has oh we got we leveled up
so we now have ice bowl cool let's use
ice bulb sweet
uh a monster did not spawn
um
let's use these healing potions so we're
already full health so we can't use
anymore i don't know why monster didn't
spawn there maybe we have some bug oh we
do have a
let me let's think about this here when
does the monster spawn
right here
when does the monster place
so yeah wherever we're placing our
monsters not getting triggered i guess
or didn't in that case i don't know i
don't know what happened there but
the monster was not on the map
uh let's see i guess would be this
is there somewhere it can place where
it's not on the map
so while it's on top of the player or
while it's on top of an x
redo it and then eventually we set it
here so do this
current monster equals
yeah i'm not sure what happened there
but we might have a little bug in this
create monster code too it looks like
so stuff to work out but overall looking
pretty good
so next steps what do we need to do we
need the
to keep track of mp if you have mp
because using your abilities to take mp
it doesn't actually use it yet so you
need to spam over and over so wizard and
cleric probably just broken
uh let's see what else and we need to
actually have stuff go and cool down
properly so
and we need to only we can either
display the cooldown
or only show stuff that's actually ready
or something like that so
we still got definitely have some issues
that need sorted out before this is
proper but we can now use abilities so
that's a pretty big step and we're out
of time and since this is the final
episode uh the rest of these edits are
going to be up to you guys
if you want me to do more of them sign
up on patreon i am going to continue
this stuff privately and probably make a
little game out of it that may be all
eventually release on steam or something
if you want access to that code sign up
at one of the source levels on patreon
or join here on
uh youtube it just helps actually
support me that's gotta be it i
definitely wanna do more stuff and i'm
probably yeah i'm gonna do it i don't
know how i'm gonna do i'm gonna i guess
i'll say that yeah i plan on doing a
little graphical interface but basically
doing the same thing making a little
story and
if i can make it at least 10 hours long
or so i'll probably put it out on steam
who knows maybe people will actually
play it but after this my next big plans
are actually to join a game jam and uh
just knock out a game jam or two so i'll
probably make a video or announce and
discord which one i'm joining and uh in
case anyone wants to join along and make
a game as well or if they allow teams
maybe i can find a few team members but
yeah that's basically my next plan as
far as content on this channel is or my
personal progression i guess too is to
jam it up
all right well thanks for watching
[Music]
you